[Musique]
le pen marine 53 ans candidate du
rassemblement national c'est votre
troisième campagne présidentielle au
travers des archives de l'ina nous
allons tenter de révéler votre adn
bonjour et bienvenue marine le pen
bonjour est d'abord avec votre toute
première apparition à la télévision
c'est une image furtive une archive de
73 un portrait de votre père jean marie
le pen qui vient de créer le front
national vous avez 5 ans
[Musique]
vous êtes la petite dernière avec le
gros nounours dans les bras et le
chandail à rayures et donc pour vous une
première apparition dans un reportage
politique sans que vous l'ayez souhaité
oui c'est vrai on a on a été très vite
mis devant les caméras mais c'était
l'époque c'était c'était la grande
époque
enfin le début de l'époque reagan de
l'époque
où en réalité en montrer la vie de
famille en fête est donc tout au long de
la vie politique de mon père on a
souvent fait l'objet de reportages mais
ça c'est effectivement la première image
avec le chien rainbow que vous ne voyez
pas mais que vous entendez et dans cet
appartement qui était un appartement
assez modeste du 15e arrondissement dans
lequel nous vivions
qui plus tard sera le logement qui est
qui et qui explosera qui sera dévasté
1993 vos vrais débuts en politique
première campagne à 24 ans vous êtes
candidate dans le xviie arrondissement
de paris
aujourd'hui marine la benjamine tout
aussi blonde que sa soeur tout aussi
imprégné de civisme familiale baptême
électoral un brin précoce peut être
objectivement 24 ans c'est une vie assez
courte mais subjectivement nous avons
été confrontés en qualité de fille de
jean marie le pen à un grand nombre
d'obstacles dans notre vie et peut-être
cela nous a forgé un caractère
plus combatifs et nous a donné une
expérience certaine du sens des choses
et de la valeur des choses 11% des voix
vous n'êtes pas élu mais est ce à ce
moment là que vous choisissez vraiment
la politique
n'en aurait été d'avoir cette campagne
je me souviens très bien c'était
l'horreur j'étais malade comme un chien
j'avais une appendicite à opérer un peu
en urgence d'une appendicite faisait
patick donc j'étais pas très très bien
dans mes baskets mais non en réalité je
sais tu es comme obélix j'étais tombé
dans la marmite depuis bien longtemps
j'avais fait déjà des campagnes de mon
père j'avais suivi des campagnes
municipales j'avais suivi des campagnes
et la trinité-sur-mer j'avais rédigé des
enveloppes pour envoyer des tracts enfin
je veux dire c'est tellement c'était mon
quotidien est presque j'avais même
résisté parce que il souhaité m me
me positionner comme candidate avant et
j'avais voulu attendre d'être
des travaux cas je pense que j'étais
déjà vocal a tout juste à peine et donc
votre choix votre choix à vous non non
c'est maintenant en réalité non pour
j'accepte d'être candidate parce que il
me le demande mais je suis encore dans
une période où en fait je n'ai pas envie
de faire de la politique je retire tout
sauf de la politique c'est pour ça que
je deviens avocat d'ailleurs je devais
avocat parce que je ne veux pas faire de
politique la politique pour moi c'est
l'horreur et je le fais parce que
personne ne veut aller face à pont ce
qu'ils faisaient bernard pons 80% au
premier tour où 85% au premier tour et
donc là pour le coup je rends service
mais j'ai pas du tout décidé de faire de
la politique et j'ai surtout pas encore
compris qu'en fait j'avais le virus et
qui met il finirait par me rattraper
donc dans la rubrique des premières fois
votre révélations médiatiques elle
arrive presque par hasard pendant la
campagne présidentielle de jean marie le
pen en 2002 vous rester dans l'ombre
mais le 22 mai 2002 deux semaines après
le second tour perdu face à jacques
chirac vous êtes envoyé au débotté sur
le plateau de france 3 pour remplacer un
cadre du parti parce que qui a contribué
à faire croire aux français que
l'intégralité des hommes politiques
étaient malhonnêtes c'est vous et c'est
vous parce que vous parce que parce que
mais oui bien sûr marty mais qui a les
soldats et
le pc vous voulez que je vous rappelle à
cet homme d'affaires parce que monsieur
alpha ne le fera plus il a oublié lui
les affaires il a oublié la lutte contre
la corruption puisqu'il a voté pour le
premier de la gamme france alors la
langue de bois et bien c'est son la
langue de bois
la sidération et l'exaspération jean luc
mélenchon sont un spectacle épuisable
révélations de vos talents de b batteuse
pour vous-même aussi ou bien vous si
vous saviez capable de tenir tête à vos
adversaires non mais bon d'abord je n'ai
pas de fascination pour tous ces gens
qui sont ministre parce que j'ai pas de
fascination pour le pouvoir donc ils ne
m'impressionnent pas du fait qu' ils ont
ces responsabilités là j'arrive sur ce
plateau personne ne veut aller en
réalité c'est ça pour commenter une
défaite parce que la défaite est lourde
1 on est au second tour de l'élection
présidentielle de 2000 on vient de vivre
quinze jours d'enfer de manifestations
de
d'insultés c'est une horreur et j'y vais
très détendue on me disant bon barbe
puisqu'on en est là autant que je dis ce
que j'ai envie de dire et je pensais pas
du tout que ça allait être le démarrage
c'est vrai de d'une carrière d'abord
médiatique en fait
qui me poussera à prendre des
responsabilités plus tard et qui
poussera dans un premier temps votre
père a à vous demander de faire toutes
les émissions de télé il dit que vous
êtes un un cheval de course et vous
voici enchaînant les plateaux et les
prises de bec mais vous ne vivez pas
dans un mouvement je vais clément
téléphone est ouverte écoute moi c'est
de vivre dans un appartement avec les
fenêtres dernière que les lapins poules
à de prétendus de prétendre des frimas
pauvres les hôtels particuliers à saint
clément chausson mais le visage je suis
né dans la ferme deux jours ce manque de
voter même mis des petits ce que je vois
mais vous c'est qu'un look est passé que
de l'eau redevienne la réalisation et
c'est mon rôle
parce que je me retienne que sa
république non que nous et son avocat
excusez moi de vous dire qu'il
assimilerait j'ai été payé par nicolas
sarkozy est absolument scandaleux terre
france de nicolas sarkozy et je dis ce
que je veux et si j'ai envie de mettre
en cause la collusion entre le service
public est prise on a vu que je le fais
je peux éventuellement expliquer ici
profiter de cette invitation qui m'est
fait d'expliquer pourquoi vous êtes une
imposture dans cette élection lite mais
je ne dénigre pas avec vous parce que
vous n'êtes pas en état ne contrôlez pas
de débat républicain vous n'êtes pas
obligé d'être agressif avec vous deux
vous n'êtes pas obligé de donner les
saisons enquête soit deux buts entre
abbas a depuis tout à l'heure c'est vous
et moi je vais vous dire est prise et
même d'autant plus c'est d'autant plus
facile à voir que vous parlez de temps
pourtant je méprise on vous rend même
plus compte en fait oui écoutez vous
êtes censés soi conseiller de quatre
caractéristiques permanent et c'est
raciste et agresser les autres des vous
enfoncez envoyé à l'éviction j'en
entends c'est une femme que je dis ici
monsieur parce que vous vous êtes
couchée ou rose ont pris valeur de ce
mois turkcell vous vous couchez en
permanence vous êtes à playa autres en
birman en jeu devant l'allemagne devant
syndicats sur neuf en juillet devant les
communautarismes suis dedans des
puissances d'argent différents voir les
banques à plat ventre mais madame le
sida wrap l'avant je suis debout mais
pour être debout je n'ai pas besoin de
salir qu'est ce qui vous a fait réagir
c'est strauss kahn oui c'est de me
strauss kahn ce que on s'est regardé
après avec avec arlette chabot et on
s'est dit mais c'est pas possible c'est
parce qu'il a dit est en fait si c'est
ce qu'ils avaient dit oui bon bah des
années des années de combat politique
c'est vrai de prises de bec de
mai cette marine de conviction de cette
marine le pen l' offensive et
vindicative on ne la voit plus
on n'entend plus comme ça la partie en
passer non mais c'est pas ça c'est que
je pense qu'on se lasse moi je me lasse
de je les dis je me lasse du bruit et de
la fureur jeu c'était pas facile c'était
d'ailleurs moins facile qu'aujourd'hui
faut un taux net où on défend des idées
qui n'était pas à la mode à l'époque
elles le sont devenus depuis mais je
pense qu'on mûrit voilà je j'ai pu 30
jeunes et plus 30 ans j'en ai plus 40
j'en ai aujourd'hui 53 je suis à ma
troisième campagne présidentielle j'ai
envie de j'ai envie d'efficacité
aujourd'hui j'ai envie
d'aller au fond des choses j'ai envie
d'apaisement aussi après cinq ans
de violences je trouve dans la société
de fracturation de division et ce dont
j'ai envie je pense que ce dont les
français aussi ont envie
revenons à présent à votre enfance et à
vos racines
[Musique]
le 2 novembre 76 à 3h45 du matin vous y
avez fait allusion une déflagration
dévastent l'immeuble où vous vivez villa
poirier dans le 15e arrondissement de
paris cinq kilos d'explosifs cela tient
plus du bombardement que du simple
attentes et malgré cela il n'y a eu que
six blessés légers parmi les voisins
dont quatre enfants sellal miracle toute
une partie de l'immeuble de cinq étages
dans monsieur le pen occupe le quatrième
s'est effondré douze appartements sont
dévastés l'immeuble étant désormais
condamné une trentaine de personnes
devront être relogées dont la famille le
pen et ce matin chaque locataire
s'employait avec l'aide des pompiers a
récupéré un minimum d'effets personnels
l'explosion a rejeté les débris jusque
sur la façade des immeubles voisins
certains étant même très éloigné
plusieurs voitures en stationnement ont
été endommagés alors que s'est-il passé
exactement dans la mesure où pouvait
avoir une idée précise formidable
explosion et alors qui les a
pratiquement jeté hors du lit et
nous sommes sortis dans le couloir et on
a vu le ciel
nous avons appelé les enfants qui se
trouvaient dans un appartement au dessus
ils ont répondu
et d'avoir appelé les voisins du dessus
et
chercher leur bébé le bébé avait été
projetée du cinquième étage au rez de
chaussée et par miracle il est encore
vivant vous avez huit ans et vous êtes
une rescapée qu'est ce que vous
comprenez alors de ce qui vient de vous
arriver je comprends qu'on veut le tuer
quoi je comprends qu'on veut nous tuer
aurait été pas seulement lui mais tout
le monde toute la famille
donc je comprends que c'est dangereux
que c'est difficile et je pense que ça
me quittera jamais vraiment en réalité
cette idée que on peut mourir pour la
politique voilà ce qui est probablement
pas la conscience que peuvent avoir les
responsables politiques qui en font de
manière entre guillemets traditionnels
il ya d'ailleurs une anecdote absolument
incroyable qui s'est déroulée parce que
ma soeur est descendu ma soeur l'aînée
est descendu par la grande échelle 1
parce que nous nous étions cinquième
étage et au 4e ou 5e et et ma soeur
cadette et moi et qui avions donc 8 et
12 ans ils nous ont descendu par une
nacelle parce qu'on était trop petite
pour descendre 5 étage par l'escalier un
jour j'étais en réunion ii fédération
dans le 92 il ya un monsieur qui est
venu voir et qui m'a dit madame le pen
je suis le pompier qui vous a descendu
par la nacelle du cinquième étage le
jour de votre attente à vous et ça m'a
fait vraiment ça a été un moment
incroyable
quarante ans plus tard c'est il fait que
la violence fait partie non pas de votre
adn mais de votre environnement depuis
le plus jeune âge oui bien sûr parce que
là c'est l'attentât qui nous a touchés
évidemment directement on était en train
de dormir c'est arrivé en pleine nuit
ça a été très traumatisants
il est d'ailleurs je pense que ma soeur
une de mes soeurs ne s'en est jamais
totalement jamais remise en fait mais
c'était tout le temps comme ça il y
avait des violences tout le temps il y
avait des attentats dans nos permanences
il y avait des manifestations qui
étaient attaqués il y avait donc oui ça
a été vraiment une période où enfin moi
je moi je comprenais que la politique
c'était difficile quoi c'était pas mal
rose c'était un chemin de verre pilé et
pour la vie de la poirier on n'a jamais
su qui avaient été les les poseurs de
bombes en 86 à nouveau un moment
d'intimité familiale devant les caméras
du journal télévisé vous avez 18 ans
jean marie le pen en privé père de trois
filles 17 22 et 26 ans le président du
front national comme beaucoup leader
politique passionné consacre plus de
temps aux réunions électorat qu'à son
foyer c'est pourquoi des retrouvailles
comme celles ci sont jalousement
protégés une chaise vide celle de
l'épousé de la mer qui a repris sa
liberté de ce fait les relations père
enfants se sont modifiées dans les
abysses papa c'est souvent le père
fouettard celui de tombes menace
des enfants si jamais elle ne travaille
pas bien apparemment ils n'ont pas l'air
d'avoir peur de vous
c'est un type gentil drôle qui danse qui
aime s'amuser qui malheureusement il ya
beaucoup de choses à faire on se voit
rarement mon père c'est quelqu'un non
vraiment je suis fier vraiment j'en suis
très fier je suis vraiment très heureuse
de m'appeler nouvelle le pen est plus en
plus une fierté ou un poids comme vous
l'avez dit ensuite ou les deux non mais
c'était les deux c'était les deux
vous savez tous les malheurs qui me sont
arrivées dans ma jeunesse dans mon
adolescence ou en fête l'été liée à la
politique donc j'ai associé la politique
à quelque chose éminemment difficile et
en même temps j'étais très fier parce
que l'agression dont nous faisions
l'objet en permanence a quand même nous
obliger à ressouder les liens on se
on se défend des les uns les autres
parce qu'on était aussi attaqué les uns
les autres et le départ de ma mère et la
manière dont ça s'est passé évidemment
n'a été rendu possible que parce que mon
père était un responsable politique
contre lequel est bien on utilisait en
fait tous y compris sa vie privée parce
que à l'époque le débat ne se posait pas
de savoir si on avait le droit
d'utiliser la vie privée des hommes
politiques contre eux on le faisait pour
personne sauf pour lui quoi alors vous
l'avez dit vous tenté de tourner le dos
à la politique en 91 vous obtenez un dea
de droit pénal vous prenez la robe
d'avocate vous défendez votre père dans
la sphère bussières mais aussi des
étrangers en situation irrégulière
menacés d'expulsion comme nordine amedi
mais que tu vas faire qu'est ce que tu
vas faire toutes les 10 minutes nourdine
appelle sa soeur du centre de rétention
du mesnil-amelot en seine-et-marne
il lui dit lui répète qu'il ne veut pas
partir pourtant le train doit l'emmener
ce soir vers marseille puis ce sera le
bateau pour l'algérie il est sous le
coup d'un arrêté d'expulsion en urgence
absolue de 1971 en 71 nordine avait 20
ans
incohérence avec ce que vous défendrez
ensuite erreur de jeunesse absolument
pas non absolument pas sait on peut très
bien lutter contre l'immigration qui est
un processus et en même temps considéré
que les immigrés sont des personnes qui
ont des droits qui méritent d'être
défendus et gelé défendu plusieurs fois
d'ailleurs nous réside à midi j'ai gagné
en réalité il avait par il rentrait
parfaitement dans les cases pour pouvoir
obtenir non seulement le droit de rester
mais la nationalité française compte
tenu de l'âge qu'il avait
par rapport aux événements d'algérie
mais c'est pas le problème j'en ai
défendu n'était pas commander il n'était
pas réellement clandestins mais c'est
pas le sujet soit savez moi j'ai fait
j'ai fait énormément de procédure comme
ça en comparution immédiate j'ai défendu
des étrangers en situation irrégulière
parce que ils ont des droits voilà ils
ont des droits il ya des textes ils ont
droit d'avoir des avocats et ça n'est
pas pour ça que je ne suis pas opposé à
la politique anarchique d'immigration je
ne souhaite pas changer les règles mais
il n'en demeure pas moins qu'il ya des
hommes des femmes et qu' ils méritent
d'être défendus dans une civilisation
comme la nôtre la rubrique suivante nous
ramène à jean marie le pen
qui est sans conteste votre mentor en
politique vous lui rendais régulièrement
hommage pour sa force tribunicienne
extraits du discours qu'il prononce au
soir du 21 avril 2002 après sa
qualification au second tour où il
reprend le n'ayez pas peur de jean paul
ii
n'ayez pas peur chers compatriotes
rentrer dans l'espérance
l'événement ces chèques mais en
attendant n'ayez pas peur de rêver vous
les petits les sans grades les exclus ne
vous laissez pas enfermer dans les
vieilles divisions de la gauche et de la
droite
vous qui avez supporté depuis 20 ans
toutes les erreurs et les malversations
des politiciens vous les mineurs les
métallos les ouvrières et ouvriers de
toutes ces industries ruiné par l'euro
mondialisme de maastricht vous les
agriculteurs ont retraite de misère est
acculé à la ruine et à la disparition
qu'est ce qui fait de votre père le
meilleur tribun de la vème république
ainsi que vous l'avez qualifier je pense
que c'est d'abord ce son talent
deuxièmement c'est sa force de
conviction vous savez on dit on ne
transmet que la foi que l'on a voilà je
pense que quand on n'y croit pas en
réalité on transmet rien et lui il
ils y croyaient ils avaient des
convictions chevillées il a une
épaisseur humaine un parcours sa
naissance ses origines modestes la perte
de son père la guerre la guerre
d'algérie tout ça si vous voulez ça ça
construisait des hommes il faut bien le
dire politique qui avait
beaucoup de beaucoup de bagages et
pardon de le dire mais quand on voit les
débats l'assemblée nationale à l'époque
les personnalités qui existaient à
l'époque et quand on voit les
personnalités aujourd'hui il ya
incontestablement une différence voilà
c'est un fait et lui avait réussi
quelque chose d'extraordinaire
d'ailleurs c'est que il avait réussi à
dompter la télévision parce que chick
chez vignancour dont il était directeur
de campagne qui était un extraordinaire
tribu un avocat fabuleux mais n'arrivait
pas n'avait pas réussi à passer à la
télévision il gardait ses grandes
envolées qui faisaient évidemment le
spectacle dans les prétoires mais qui ne
passait pas la télévision et jean marie
le pen il alla me la modernité en fait
de d'être capable de s'exprimer et avec
ses qualités tribunicienne un meeting et
en même temps à la télévision ce qui
était pas tout à fait évident à l'époque
la télévision vous l'avez beaucoup suivi
quand ils étaient invités on voit très
souvent dans les archives de l'heure de
vérité c'est lui qui vous a appris la la
bagarre avec les journalistes le rapport
de forces lors des interviews dont il
apprend rien mon père il nous apprend
rien en l'observant oui voilà c'est tout
parce que il n'y a pas le temps
je me pose sûr qu'ils aient le goût
d'être en réalité pour nous apprendre
quoi que ce soit en fait il s'est
retrouvé avec trois grandes filles il
savait pas trop comment faire quand ma
mère est parti j'avais 16 ans ma soeur
en avait 20 ou 21 et et la grande on
avait 27 bon il se retrouve avec trois
filles c'est pas comment ça fonctionne
tout ça à quelle heure on a le droit de
sortir de quoi on a besoin
il a géré comme il pouvait mais c'est
vrai que on vit on vit on respire on
mange on dort on écoute on parle
politique tout le temps tout le temps
tout le temps et que oui c'est sûr que
c'est une forme de formation continue un
peu comme les enfants de musiciens avec
leurs parents musiciens ou les enfants
au peintre avec leurs parents peintre
quoi et pourtant ce père et mentor vous
allez l'exclure du front national le
parti qu'il a fondé et dont il a voulu
retirer son propre nom c'était en 2015
et je dois dire que j'ai honte que le
président de la présidente du front
national porte mon nom et je
souhaiterais d'ailleurs qu'elle le
perdre de plus rapidement possible elle
peut le faire soit en se mariant avec
son concubin soit peut-être avec
monsieur philippe ou avec quelqu'un
d'autre que moi je fait pas que la
présidente du front national s'appelle
le pen c'est une violence
oui il est capable d'être il est capable
d'être très violent quand il est
contredit quand il est blessé aussi je
pense je pense qu'il a été très blessée
par cette situation honnêtement il m'a
pas tellement laissé le choix je pouvais
pas faire autrement il était entré dans
un processus de provocation à mon égard
qui faisaient que il était dans une
démarche de sabotage en fait de ce que
je souhaitais faire de ce que les
adhérents en fait du front national
aussi me demandait de faire parce que je
leur ai proposé quelque chose ils m'ont
dit oui et il y avait du mal à le
supporter et quand quand il est blessé
il peut être terriblement brutale et
terriblement violent dans les propos
qu'il exprime mais voilà c'est son
caractère il est comme ça il a il a des
qualités il ya des revers de médaille
quoi
rancunier très rancunier ou capable de
sa douce pire avec les années il n'est
pas rancunier il n'est pas rancunier
c'est pour ça qu'il a pardonné
d'ailleurs à son ex femme non il n'est
pas rancunier je ne suis pas non plus
d'ailleurs non
non c'est vraiment un des traits de
caractère qui n'a pas d'ailleurs il a
pardonné à tout le monde y compris à des
gens à qui il aurait pu lui pardonner
pour le coup tout au long de sa carrière
non il n'a pas il n'a pas ce défaut là
mais c'est vrai qu'il est capable
d'avoir des mots
il sait exactement où taper pour avoir
les mots les plus les plus blessants
qui soit après il oublie mais quand on
est en face il faut être sûr il faut
être capable d'oublier aussi moi je sais
le faire mais d'autres probablement
n'ont pas su le faire un dirigeant
politique à présent dont être allé
chercher sinon le soutien du moins là la
poignée de main est l'image c'était
pendant la campagne de 2017 vladimir
poutine rencontré à moscou
un petit salon modeste du kremlin qui
sert à des rencontres informelles mais
les caméras sont bien là pour
immortaliser l'instant marine le pen a
enfin obtenu la rencontre censée lui
octroyer sa stature internationale et
elle a du mal à cacher son émotion merci
monsieur marc
entrevue vous le savez j'ai depuis
longtemps pour que la france et la
russie reprennent des relations une
candidate à l'élection présidentielle
qui s'engagent à oeuvrer pour une levée
des sanctions européennes contre moscou
vladimir poutine ne peut qu'approuver
même s'il se défend de toute ingérence
dans le scrutin que vous dit cette image
de 2017 à la lumière de 2022 c'est une
image qu'elle est très importante parce
que la réalité c'est que au fur et à
mesure des années et au fur et à mesure
des choix qui ont été faits par l'union
européenne la russie n'a eu de cesse que
de s'éloigner en fête de l'europe moi je
pense qu'au départ elle vladimir poutine
il souhaitait que la russie ait des
relations avec l'europe et
accessoirement avec la france et à force
de l'en avoir éloigné s'est tourné vers
la chine je pense que c'est une très
mauvaise une très mauvaise
il dès qu'on a eue là d'ailleurs parce
que il est beaucoup plus dangereux de
voir la russie avec la chine que la
russie en ayant des relations avec
l'europe mais là on est deux ans en fait
après les attentats du bataclan et moi
je vais voir vladimir poutine et je
défends l'idée que la russie qui peut
être par ailleurs un adversaire dans
certains endroits un concurrent dans
d'autres on le voit bien en afrique
aujourd'hui 1 mais incontestablement
peut être un allié dans la lutte contre
le fondamentalisme islamiste et je
n'aurai de cesse d'ailleurs que de
pouvoir rencontrer des dirigeants de
pays pour organiser
en fait sur des sujets qui sont des
sujets qu'on peut avoir en commun des
points de convergence voyez là je
rencontre vladimir poutine j'ai
rencontré il ya peu le président le
premier ministre polonais pour le coup
les deux peuvent pas s'entendre ils se
détestent cordialement leur pays sont
dans une guerre diplomatique majeur mais
parce que je pense que c'est le rôle de
la france le rôle de la france et de
cette puissance d'éclipsé d'être à
équidistance c'est d'être capable de
parler aux uns et aux autres et
accessoirement le moment venu de
rapprocher les positions des uns et des
autres mais dans cette visite est dans
cette poignée de main il y avait un peu
plus que des considérations stratégiques
ou de la realpolitik qui avez vous
l'avez exprimé une forme d'admiration
quand vladimir poutine vous l'avez dit
est ce qu'elle est ce qu'elle a faibli
depuis non mais administration non mais
pardon mais essayons d'avoir une vision
un petit peu cohérente la bonne humeur
poutine est un dirigeant politique qui a
réussi quand même à
arracher
de l'effondrement économique
de
l'effondrement social un pays qui a vécu
des décennies de
bottes soviétique puis une décennie de
pillage ultralibéral voilà c'est ça qui
récupère et on peut avoir à son égard
énormément de réserve on peut s'en
méfier on peut le considérer brutal on
peut tout ce qu'on veut mais on ne peut
pas jeudi à traiter par le mépris le
dirigeant politique qu'il est parce que
il a réussi à faire de la russie à
nouveau un acteur de premier plan à
nouveau un pays qui tire la route sur le
plan économique donc moi j'essaye d'être
objective j'essaye de ne pas être
subjectif parce que quand on est
dirigeant politique on ne peut pas être
subjectif il ne faut pas être subjectif
il faut être
très comment dire lucide sur ce qu'il
est sur ce qu'est la russie mais il faut
aussi être capable de comprendre
pourquoi il agit comme ça qu'est ce
qu'il a derrière la tête qu'est ce qu'il
souhaite faire et qu'est ce qu'ils
cherchent à obtenir par la brutalité qui
l'expriment maintenant c'est sûr que ce
qui s'est passé là la guerre en ukraine
est
inadmissible et insupportable
est à mon avis impardonnable mais je
pense surtout c'est une gigantesque
erreur de sa part
rubrique suivante
[Musique]
180 degrés comme le revirement que vous
avez opéré sur la question de l'euro
j'ai proposé mois un plan concerté
organisée planifiée de sortie de l'euro
avec une initiative franco allemande
parce que le peuple français et le
peuple allemand messieurs excusez moi de
parler de gros mots 1 les peuples ne
veulent plus payer pour les autres
est-ce qu'en politique on peut assumer
d'avoir fait fausse route et changer
d'avis alors d'abord c'est votre bière
c'est le biais que vous utilisez la
réalité c'est que d'abord j'ai pris
conscience que les français ne
souhaitait pas sortir de l'euro j'ai
déjà il ya un moment donné on était trop
loin l'euro était une mauvaise monnaie
elle a été mal conçue elle a eu des
conséquences très néfastes sur notre
économie mais nous étions trop loin au
bout de 17 ans en fait pour que les
français arrivent encore à se projeter
dans une monnaie nationale et puis entre
temps cette monnaie qui aurait dû mourir
si on avait laissé les règles de l'union
européenne telle qu'elle était en fait
pour ne pas mourir l'union européenne a
complètement changé les règles cirque
pour que l'euro n'implose pas ils ont
fait de la création monétaire ce qui
était interdit par des traités ils ont
fait même énormément de création
monétaire ils ont changé les règles de
de maastricht c'est à dire que les
critères de maastricht ont disparu au
fur à mesure du temps c'est vrai mais
ces réformes dahoui ont été prises après
votre changement de doctrine vous avez
changé à l'été 2010 non pardon la
création monétaire s'étaient antérieurs
à 2010 est désolé d'être en désaccord
avec vous et vous
vous le ferez
confirmé c'était avant 2017 donc voilà
donc si vous voulez le fait que les
règles aient changé que les français ne
souhaitent pas en nous demandait de
faire ce que nous avions à faire mais
dans le cadre de l'euro et que de
surcroît nous avions trouvé des alliés
pour pouvoir opérer une modification du
fonctionnement de l'union européenne de
l'intérieur de l'union européenne et
bien tout cela nous a poussés
effectivement en 2017 après l'élection
présidentielle a
abandonné le référendum parce qu en fait
au départ c'était un référendum que nous
souhaitions mettre en oeuvre sur la
sortie de l'europe et de l'euro un homme
a présentes dont l'ombre et l'héritage
plane sur cette campagne
[Musique]
face à de gaulle mais quelle de gaulle
nous avons choisi pour vous celui de la
guerre d'algérie janvier 1960 après la
semaine des barricades d'alger menées
par les partisans de l'algérie française
le général ne lâche rien aux insurgés et
réaffirme le principe
d'autodétermination pour l'algérie dans
la nuit d'alger ce soir de vendredi tout
le monde attend aux barricades comme
dans les postes de garde insurgés et
militaires tout le monde attend d'une
même attente le discours que va
prononcer le général de gaulle
il roule pas j'ai pris au nom de la
france la décision que voici
les algériens
disposeront et librement de leur destin
or deux catégories de gens ne veulent
pas de ce libre choix
d'abord l'organisation rebelle qui
prétendent cessez le feu
que signe préalable je traite avec elle
par privilège de l'avenir politique de
l'algérie cela je ne le ferai pas
d'autre part
certains français de souche et si et je
renonce à
l'autodétermination mais je dise que
tout est fait que le sort des algériens
est d'ores et déjà décidé cela non plus
je ne le ferai pas de gaulle qui d'une
certaine façon rompt définitivement avec
les français d'algérie et avec ceux qui
lui faisaient confiance et qui avait
contribué à le ramener au pouvoir que
vous inspire tellement réalisez vous de
montrer à
un des seuls actes une des seules
décisions en fait du général de gaulle
avec lesquels je suis profondément des
accords parce que pour tout le reste la
vision qu'il a de la france la vision
qu'il avait du monde la vision de
l'indépendance nécessaire même la vision
de l'europe un qui défend des tout ça me
va plutôt bien mais là il y commet un
abandon une trahison je pense que le
terme est quand même relativement juste
puisque il avait suivi dé cette trahison
elle a suivi des déclarations qui
étaient des déclarations auxquelles les
les les français d'algérie ont cru et
puis surtout il commettra après un
abandon des harkis
dans des conditions qui restent quand
même une tache sur son parcours quoi
qu'on en dise encore aujourd'hui on
parle de
de réparer je veux dire cette
épouvantable faute qui a consisté à
mettre des les harkis qui avaient versé
leur sang qui avait choisi la france
dans des camps les y laisser mourir sans
même scolariser les enfants enfin ça n'a
pas été un joli joli et ça a laissé des
cicatrices chez beaucoup de français qui
ont dû partir
du jour au lendemain en laissant tout
derrière eux leur vie leur commerce lors
leur logement enfin sont des cicatrices
quand vous parlez avec eux je vous
assure ça vous tire les larmes
objectivement voilà bon ben c'est comme
ça dans le parcours dans le parcours
d'un homme politique il y as parfois 99%
de choses auxquelles vous pouvez adhérer
et puis il ya 1 % mais sur 1% et il est
quand même un peu fondamentale séquence
suivante
[Musique]
alors zéro pointé pour ce qui ressemble
à un dérapage nous direz vous êtes en
campagne nous sommes en 2012 et vous
avez un accrochage avec un militant que
jean luc mélenchon
abba et merci non mais c'est très gentil
merci vous confirmez vous confirmer ce
que je dis en permanence
vous l'avez gay vous l'avez gagnée la
voiture non non vous avez vous l'avez
gagnée avec de travail à chaque fois que
les types creevy melançon ce sont les
français d'origine maghrébine à chaque
fois c'est un maghrébin est au volant
d'une belle voiture c'est donc qu'il a
gagné au loto non mais celui-là je le
connaissais bien parce que c'est un type
d'hénin ça vous savez dans les petites
villes comme ça tout le monde se connaît
et c'est vrai que jean luc mélenchon a
complètement abandonné les principes qui
étaient les siens de défense de la
république de la laïcité
parce que il est allé de reggae draguer
vois je ne sais pas comment dire autre
chose draguer un électorat d'origine
maghrébine qui fait que quelques années
plus tard c'est à dire aujourd'hui il
est le défenseur de l'islamisme il est
le contempteur de la laïcité il accepte
tous les accommodements
scandaleux avec les règles de la
république
il supporte le voile enfin je veux dire
tout il a complètement changé
complètement changé une madeleine
[Musique]
alors je ne sais pas si on a visé juste
si elle figure dans votre panthéon
on a choisi pour vous une grande voix
féminine
[Musique]
les yeux partie de la mine touristes un
doublet mort
tu ne dors plus dit tu n'es que le rhum
brun de toi même
seul dans la rue tu regardé comme une
âme en peine
ah j'ai tous les soirs sous sa fenêtre
ont peu de bois
je sais bien que tu l'as d'or
qu'elle a de jolis yeux
mais tu es trop jeune encore
jouer les amoureux
et grâce à
sa musique le plus joli que tout le site
a dit
[Musique]
tu vas chanter tant que tu veux elle ne
dépend pas aux séries ah oui à mon
panthéon mais sans aucune difficulté à
tout en haut une femme extraordinaire
une artiste une voix une beauté une une
intelligence qu'est ce qui vous touche
tous tout d'abord son talent ça ça sa
solitude ça ça c'était une femme très
malheureuse terriblement malheureuse qui
attend perdu toute sa vie enfin j'veux
dire qu'à vraiment pas eu de chance et
en même temps elle a eu beaucoup d'amis
elle a été très émue
vraiment cessé au delà je dire du talent
incroyable
elle m'a toujours touché jeu à chaque
fois qu'il ya un film sur l d'ailleurs
je vais voir j'en sors en général en
pleurant parce que je trouve que cette
vie et et tragique qu elle a une vie
tragique voilà tragique une archive que
nous montrons à tous les candidats celle
de l' alerte verte
[Musique]
1974 aviez six ans première campagne
présidentielle de votre père est aussi
celle d'un drôle de candidats en
pull-over rouge
et vous savez ce qui va se passer eh
bien nous allons bientôt manquer de
l'eau et c'est pourquoi je bois devant
vous un verre d'eau précieuse puisque
avant la fin du siècle si nous
continuons un tel débordement elle
manquera à lundi je vous dis au revoir
et j'espère vous revoir pour vous
expliquer notre projet global d'avenir
merci mes amis
il ay pas complètement temps aura
atteint
rené dumont le premier candidat
écologiste qui a fait un un peu plus de
voix que jean marie le pen d'ailleurs à
cette élection mais qui n'a pas été
beaucoup entendu à l'époque c'est
dommage
oui enfin c'est dommage la réalité c'est
que c'est le modèle économique qui a été
développée plus tard qui est le
vrai modèle qui tuent notre planète
c'est le modèle ultra libéral c'est le
modèle fondé sur le libre échange sur le
moins disant social sur
l'utilisation le pillage en fait de la
planète c'est ça auquel il faut mettre
fin pour pouvoir retrouver
pour pouvoir défendre l'environnement
véritablement la pollution enregistrée
est comme moi sur le premier non mais la
pollution existait mais je vais tout
nous dit là d'ailleurs depuis cette
période là que c'est par la technologie
aussi qu'on arrive à résoudre les
problèmes qui sont la conséquence de
l'activité humaine
vous voyez c'est c'est grâce aux progrès
en fait qu'on arrive à faire en sorte
que
les industries polluantes - que le
nucléaire pollue moins que c'est grâce
par exemple aux usines de désalinisation
de l'eau que l'on peut demain on règle
déjà mais on règle aura encore plus de
mal le manque d'eau dans le monde parce
qu'il avait raison il ya des endroits
qui manquent d'eau aujourd'hui au moment
où nous nous parlons et donc moi je
crois beaucoup progrès je veux dire je
pense pas que les choses soient fixés
que l'on de faille faire indéfiniment
siècle après siècle avec les éléments
technologiques que nous avons non on va
trouver on découvre des choses tous les
jours pour pouvoir améliorer la
situation mais il n'en demeure pas moins
que le modèle économique lui s'ils
continuent si on continue à le choisir
au lieu du localisme au lieu de la
proximité et bien on finira par mal
vivre c'est pas tellement la planète qui
souffrent sont les hommes qui souffrent
d'un ace vous n'êtes pas écologiste
canal historique on a bien compris la
écoutant
jean-marie le pen disait parler de
l'écologie comme la la nouvelle religion
des bobos gogos s'est longtemps était
une expression en partie oui non mais
c'est pas ça non moi je suis plutôt je
suis plutôt attaché à ces problématiques
écologistes mais j'essaie de les
regarder par laure par le vrai bout de
la lorgnette pas par le mauvais bout de
la lorgnette oui une rencontre pour
finir
c'est une parole trouvait parmi les
trésors de linas celle de l'écrivain
rené barjavel une archive de 1957 dans
l'émission présence protestante le thème
qui est judas
pour vous qui est judas
pour moi ça ne fait pas de doute judas
c'est vous c'est moi c'est n'importe
lequel des auditeurs qui nous écoutent
et qui nous regarde en ce moment c'est
chaque chrétien c'est chaque homme parce
que si on s'écarte justement des limites
du fait divers des limites temporelles
de la passion
judas prend une signification
universelle
regardez ce qui lui arrive jésus lui
donne le pain et il trahi jésus en
faisant semblant de l'est mais il vend
celui qu'il aime pour trente deniers
quel est celui de nous sincèrement qu'il
se reconnaîtrait pas là dedans
et
je crois
que si judas et chacun de nous il est
aussi nous touche
avez vous connu des judas marine le pen
et avez-vous pour eux autant d'empathie
et de compréhension que le bar je
pourrais faire plusieurs équipes de foot
mais avec les judas que j'ai rencontré
mme hom c'est normal qu'ils fassent
preuve de deux comme ça qu'ils
pardonnent
il faut réussir à pardonner mais vous
mais c'est non il y en a quand même à
qui je pardonnerai pas parce que vous
voyez j'ai beaucoup de
jeux j'arrive à pardonner la faiblesse
dame oui je je la faiblesse quand avoir
peur craindre pour soi à craindre pour
sa famille ne pas avoir la force le
courage je peux je peux pardonner ça ce
que je pardonne pas c'est la duplicité
ça ce que je ne pardonne pas c'est celui
qui justement vous regarde dans les yeux
vous dit tu peux compter sur moi il ya
aucun problème et pendant qu'il vous dit
ça il est déjà en train de vous trahir
sa jeu j'ai vraiment énormément de mal à
à pardonner ça c'est la politique
paraît-il
au terme de ce voyage dans les archives
de l'ina y at il un morceau essentiel de
votre adn marine le pen que nous avons
manqué
non si ce n'est tout ce qui concerne ma
vie privée parce que tout ça c'est la
femme politique c'est la femme publique
mais je n'en suis pas moins femme et je
pense que bien souvent les gens oublient
cela c'est que derrière nous sommes des
hommes des femmes avec nos tristesses
avec nos faiblesses avec nos souffrances
avec nos doutes aussi de temps en temps
et c'est aussi ce que j'essaye de faire
comprendre dans cette campagne
présidentielle c'est que on ne vote pas
seulement pour un projet on vote aussi
pour une personnalité et c'est la
personnalité qui a forgé le parcours qui
est aussi celle qui demain sera amené à
prendre des décisions
merci non ils ne peuvent menacer à vous
[Musique]